The joe rogan experience,
you've,
um,
you've kicked the green bitch.
Yes,
yes.
After a 24 year intense
relationship with the,
uh,
the green goddess or the Green Bitch,
depending on what mood she's in,
I had to stop.
Um,
and uh,
I've come in for some,
I've convinced for some,
for some criticism for their son and
I feel it's important to say that,
uh,
I hugely value and a love cannabis.
I think it's a wonderful
herbal ally and I think that,
I don't think that I would ever have
written my books off historical mystery if
I had not encountered
cannabis rather late in life.
I did not smoke,
uh,
Eddie Dope until I was 37 years old and
I'm now 62 wire and roughly rad about
the age of 38.
That's when I started getting into
historical mysteries for that.
It was all,
of course,
it's total stoner style.
Absolutely.
Before that it was all carried.
The fairs,
you know,
so,
but suddenly something opened
up for me and I'm very,
and I'm very grateful
to the herb for that.
And initially my eye,
again,
I need to emphasize this.
I think the problem I eventually
ended up having with cannabis,
it's not the fault of cannabis,
it's the fault of Graham Hancock.
I think my relationship
became abusive with the herb.
It was not initially.
Initially it was something I
would do evenings and weekends.
I would not try to write
while I was actually stoned.
I would do my days work and then chill
out in the evening with a pipe or a
joint.
That was,
that was how it was for
me for quite awhile.
And I went through my first
big historical mystery book,
the sign and the seal,
uh,
which was published in
1992 with that pattern.
In other words,
that I would be,
I would be smoking only after I down
tools at the end of the evening and I was
ready to chill.
Um,
and that worked fine.
But then when I started,
when I started writing
fingerprints of the gods,
which was the biggest book I've,
I've ever done,
a 5 million copy bestseller
all around the world,
when I started writing that,
I thought,
I'll experiment.
Let's see if I can be stoned and right.
And I discovered that I could,
I couldn't be stolen.
Right.
And I like being stuck
so much that in a way it,
it urged me to just write all the time,
you know,
because then I had this,
I had this incredibly good reason
to be stoned all the time and,
and um,
it took away all the physical boredom
of sitting there in my chair in front of
my computer screen,
just everything went away and I went into,
drifted into this space where I could
explore ideas and manifest those ideas
down,
down on the page.
And I literally,
that's when I began what was to become
ultimately an abusive relationship with
cannabis,
which that I would fire up in those days,
might my joint or my pipe at
a nine or 10 in the morning.
And I would,
I'm a hard worker.
I work 16 hours a day very
often when I'm writing.
So come two o'clock the next morning,
I'd still be there smoking away.
Um,
and as the years went by,
this became a permanent
daily pattern for me.
Whether I was writing or not,
I would be stoned from the moment I
got up until the moment I went to bed.
And most people who came by my
house or talk to me on the phone,
they would have had absolutely
no idea because I was,
I was completely in control.
I didn't seem hi,
I could hold a rational conversation.
I was,
I was just fine.
Um,
and I've just felt,
I just felt really good.
Uh,
and this is how it went on for many years.
later on about in the early to that
Renova 2005 actually I think perhaps a
little earlier,
one of my kids told me that,
you know,
this stuff,
this smoke is,
you don't need to have
combustion products.
Why don't you use a vaporizer?
So I bought myself a volcano
and on the Internet and,
and um,
and then I heard that the
British government was going
to ban the use of ban all
peripherals.
So I bought myself two more volcanoes.
Volcanoes are quite expensive,
but that shows how dedicated I was to
make sure that you're covering your bases.
I had to make sure that
I covered my bases.
Um,
and then I would be vaporizing from nine
in the morning until two o'clock the
next morning,
seven days a weekend,
and increasingly strong strains.
And this is one thing that I would say
if we lived in a regime and irrational
regime where there was no attempt by
the government to police our states of
consciousness,
we could have much more choice in
the kind of cannabis we get hold of.
For example,
I would have liked to have canvas
with much more CBD and maybe less THC.
But the varieties I
were smoking were very,
very THC,
THC,
uh,
loaded as the difference in effect.
Well,
okay.
I mean the,
it depends how much you buy
into the research on this,
but,
but the law,
a lot of good science has been done.
And the suggestion is that
THC can promote or reveal.
I don't want to,
I don't want to blame the herb.
Anything I,
it can reveal certain psychotic
tendencies in oneself.
And this is the well known paranoia,
which,
which many people associate with,
with smoking cannabis.
The CBD is an antipsychotic agent.
So the natural herb is
balanced with CBD and THC and,
and it looks after you very well,
but where we go into intensive
breeding of the herb,
focusing on the element
that makes you really high,
which is the Thc,
then we get,
uh,
get a herb that is somewhat unbalanced
as a result of the interference of,
uh,
of,
of humanity and,
and,
but you get more bang for your buck.
You know,
that's a very,
that's a very strong herb.
And I began to like a particular
variety called cheese,
I think it's called cheese because
it smells like old socks or,
or,
um,
Stilton in like a blue cheese.
And a,
I found a grower who
lived local to me who,
who was just heading
amazing green fingers and,
and I would,
I would buy from him and um,
and I would sometimes have,
you know,
five or six ounces of the herb in my
house cause I was blazing through this
stuff at the vendors at a tremendous rate.
That's enough to you where you
could get in trouble for that.
So that's where the paranoia
starts to become legitimate,
you know,
because actually they can numb,
they can break down your door and they
can confiscate your home and take away
your liberty and fuck you up forever.
You know,
they can do that.
And,
and so every time I had a
ring at the door or you know,
a car came up the street,
I would,
you know,
get,
get paranoid and get paranoid.
And you were high and I
was high and I was high.
You get paranoid when you were a high,
well,
this is one of the reasons why,
look what happened to me
was that run about 2003,
I started for reasons
of research initially,
uh,
working with Iowasca,
the vine of souls.
This is the powerful psychedelic brew,
which has been consumed by shamanistic
cultures in the Amazon for thousands and
thousands of years.
And it's not called the
vine of souls for nothing.
It's a,
uh,
it,
it's a,
it's an extraordinary
portal into other realms.
And,
and in some ways,
those realms are associated with death
and perhaps of what waits for us after
death.
Nobody knows the answer to that.
But in I was,
you have certain experiences relating to
that and right from the beginning when
I started to drink Iowasca,
I mean this sounds nuts to anybody who
hasn't done DMT or who hasn't drunk
Iowasca but you do meet
intelligent entities and more
and more around the world,
people drinking Iowasca a meeting,
this goddess figure,
she might appear as a serpent,
she might appear as a woman,
she might appear as some
kind of panther or Jaguar,
a very powerful,
tough love kind of lady who reveals to
you the truth about yourself and just
says,
you know,
you fucking deal with it
cause that's how you are.
And what the truth that was revealed
to me from quite early on was my
relationship with cannabis and got out
of balance and I needed to get it back
into balance.
And of course I ignored those
messages completely because I was so,
I was so much in,
in love with my cannabis relationship,
but that my wife said that
really it was like a head,
a mistress.
You know,
who I spent all my time with was the
camp was the cannabis rather than rather
than her,
and this went on for many,
many years.
Now the paranoia aspect,
okay,
I'm going to bare my heart here.
And you know,
I believe in being honest,
the paranoia aspect began to affect my
relationship with my beloved partner,
Santa,
who I just love from the bottom
of my heart and she is the best,
the most,
the most pure hearted,
generous,
spirited,
loving lady.
It's possible,
possible to imagine,
but I started to develop all
kinds of suspicions about her,
which were completely groundless.
I started to imagine all sorts of stuff
we're going on and then I started to act
to act towards her as though
those suspicions were real.
And all of this was also related
to my consumption of cannabis.
It was not caused by my
consumption of cannabis.
I think this is a latent
aspect of my own personality.
It was being revealed
by this over abuse of,
of the,
of the cannabis herp and,
and therefore I was making my beautiful
partner's life a misery sometimes,
not every day,
but sometimes.
And she was patiently
putting up with this,
but she was suffering and we
went down to Brazil in October,
2011 and if I had been told when we got
on that plane and went down to Brazil,
that when I came back two weeks later,
I would probably never
smoked cannabis again.
I would have laughed in the face
of the person who told me that.
But the encounters that I had
with the spirit of Iowasca,
whatever that is,
I'm willing to accept that
there is no spirit of Iowasca,
that it's all something we
generate out of our brains.
But for me,
she manifests as a real,
like a goddess and the
encounters I had with that,
and I do think she's real.
That's just my personal belief system.
And those encounters that I had were
incredibly powerful and she took me to a
place that was something like hell and
she took me to a place that was something
like the judgment scene in
the ancient Egyptian religion.
Now the judgment scene is a place where
your heart is weighed in the scales
against the feather of truth and harmony
and cosmic justice and you do not want
your heart to be heavy in those skills.
You want to be able to look
back on your life and say,
I did good.
I did not add to the misery in the world.
I did something worthwhile
with this incredible gift
of life that the university
gave me and I and,
and everything you've done every second,
every minute of your life
is completely transparent.
Every thought,
every action,
everything you did from the moment that
you became conscious until the moment of
your death is laid out before you
and there's no hiding from it.
Like we great at creating illusions
about our own behavior and persuading
ourselves that we're behaving just
fine in the judgment hall of Osiris,
which is also called the hall of mark,
where the scene takes place.
All of that stripped away
and you confront the truth.
And I was put there and I confronted
the truth about myself and I saw the way
that I was behaving
towards my partner and,
and,
and I was shown that this
had to stop otherwise,
otherwise I was going to
pay a huge price for it.
And it,
I had a series of terrifying,
terrifying experiences,
which my partner saw the science I've
shared with me because we were drinking
IOWASCA together.
And at a certain point entities came to
her and she had the experience of her
heart being pulled out of her chest.
And the entity said to her,
and she thought she was going to die.
we're going to do this to
you to teach grammar lesson.
And Santa's communicated that to me.
And I would rank that as probably the
single most terrifying night of my entire
life.
And I've had some terrifying nights
that was just absolutely scared,
rigid.
And I,
and I came out of that with,
uh,
a feeling of very clear feeling in a,
in Iowasca we have sharings the next
day after you've drunk the brew,
you share with the rest of the group who
you've drunk with the experiences you
had the night before,
as much as you want to share.
And what I shared,
because I still didn't believe
that I could stop smoking cannabis.
What I shared was that I was going to
change my relationship with cannabis and,
and to get to a place where cannabis was
serving me again rather than me serving
her.
Um,
and,
and that's what I believed.
But when I got back to England,
long flight,
what's the first thing I do?
I get out my vaporizer,
get out my stash,
fire up the vaporizer,
and fill a nice bag of
the vapor.
You said sort of stylistically,
well,
I miss it.
You know,
this was a,
that would be a cannabis
is such a beautiful sensual
ally if she's used right.
And what do you think?
It's just an imbalance issue
with the CBD THC ratio and the,
let me,
let me just,
let me just finish with what,
with what happened to me.
So I fill up the bag and I'm down there
in my basement and I take the first and
I take the first drawer and I'm suddenly
filled with the most intense feelings
of horror and loading.
And it is exactly like I'm back in
that space that Iowaska took me to,
and I try a second puff and I can't do it.
I physically could not continue.
I,
I knew that I just,
I just could not continue.
I expressed the vapor out of the bag,
I crumpled up the bag,
I put it away.
And the next day I got rid
of several ounces of coke.
Cannabis.
Yeah,
I know,
I know.
It's terrible.
It's a terrible thing to do.
But,
but,
but for me it was the right thing to do.
24 years,
nonstop relationship with cannabis,
definitely abusing the herb.
I had got to the point where the only
rational course of action was what I was
shown in Iowasca,
which was to stop.
And I don't know whether it was because
there was way too much THC and not
enough CBD,
or whether it was just me not being
responsible for my own behavior.
I go,
uh,
go around,
you know,
saying that I believe
in adult responsibility,
and I do,
but I don't think I was being responsible.
I don't think I was using the
herb in a responsible way.
I don't think I was using
it in a respectful way,
and I paid a price for that.
[inaudible]
okay.
Freaks and geeks level.